literature is of course something that
gives you an enormous pleasure that is
essential good literature is a
extraordinary experience of of pleasure
of entertainment but it's not only that
I think good literature is something
that enrich very much your sensibility
your imagination and I think good
literature great literature develops in
in readers a critical attitude towards
the world when you return to real life
after experiencing you know the ability
the richness of war and peace or a
donkey shot
lemis Arab by Viktor ego or all the very
great works of literature I think you
are much more sensible to the
deficiencies of real life to everything
that is wrong because it's unjust unfair
or brutal in in in the world as it is so
I think this critical attitude towards
the world which i think is essential to
change things to improve society and to
correct the deficiencies of the of the
real war is something something from
what you are much more aware if you are
impregnated of good literature I think
that is one of the most important social
and political and moral effects of good
literature you understand better what is
wrong in the in life you discovered
real life is never up to fulfill your
appetites your desires your dreams and I
think this is an essential aspect of
progress because if you don't have
citizens that are aware that things are
wrong that things are unsophisticated of
off of society you are not mobilized to
change things to reform what is what is
wrong and in this sense I think
literature in particular and culture in
general play a fundamental role in what
the civilization in what is progress I
am convinced that for example Democratic
culture culture based on freedom and
respect of human rights was something
that was possible because we had people
that were sensible eyes by art by
literature by culture in general about
the sufferance --is the injustice the
inequalities the abuses who were so
extended in in in real life so I think
literature is pleasure but it's also a
very important instrument to move
forward in in life and that is the
reason why all dictators have been
always trying to create systems to
control literature they were aware that
in literature they had an enemy someone
who was a way of resisting you know
abuses and particularly this kind of
total
control that the dictatorship tried to
impose in a society